كما تعرفون فان طائره اف 16 هي مشهوره جدا
حول العالم وتمتلكها اكثر من 25 دوله وقد
انتجنا اكثر من ثلاثه الاف طائره من هذا
الطراز وسلاح الجو الملكي البحريني كان
اول سلاح جويا في المنطقه ممن حصل عليها
في اواخر الثمانينيات ومطلع تسعينيات
القرن الماضي واليوم هم اول سلاح جوي يحصل
على احدث نسخه من الطائره وهي اف 16 بلوكس
[موسيقى]
طائره تمثل التحسين المستمر على النسخ
السابقه وتحمل رادارات المتقدمه ومده خدمه
تبلغ 12 الف ساعه ومحركا متقدما سيدفعها
الى مستويات اعلى
[موسيقى]
والدول التي تشتري المنتجات من لوك هيد
مارتن لا تحصل على افضل المنتجات في
العالم فحسب بل تصبح جزءا من عائله امم
تشارك نفس المنتجات وبالتالي بامكانها
العمل معها بشكل متوافق مما يوفر خيارات
سياسيه لقاده تلك الدول لتشكيل التحالفات
العسكريه مع الدول الاخرى ذات التوجهات
المتشابهه كما انها تستفيد من التقدم
التكنولوجي الذي توفره شركه لوك هيد في
المجالات كافه
[موسيقى]